Hi Doc, DR, a chemo 2.5 years ago, I'm not really sure what this means here, but chemo
2.5 years ago, but the last six months, the neuropathy in my feet, legs, and above
these left finger and arm. It is slowly getting worse and painful. I'm taking B12, the nutritional
yeast, what else can I do? We talked about neuropathy above there. Think about getting a rebuilder.
Make sure that you're doing the ion pro wave, help detox the chemotherapy. The vitamin B6
is really helpful for healthy rebuilders too. That is a good thing to add. Those are the
key things right there. I had pro waves help detox that make sure you're talking about detox.
I had pro wave. You also got to talk about property animals. I don't know if you've stopped
doing that or you're still doing those. Saunas can be very helpful for detoxification.
Go back in. Hey, you have access to the seventh basis of detox course right there. Look at that.
That will be helpful for you. Vitamin B6 is helpful for rebuilding herbs with their
opathy. So make sure that you have adequate vitamin B6. Take it a little bit of extra B6.